tôt le même prénom que ma mère sa faim
droz y penser
michel rivard a toujours une pensée pour
sa mère et de son décès est née l'idée
d'un projet théâtral autobiographique
baptisé l'origine de mes espèces je suis
tombé du ciel pour voulu prévu ma mère
est décédée quatre ans maintenant et il
ya des choses que je n'aurais jamais pu
aborder de son vivant par respect pour
elle loge était orphelin je pouvais me
repencher sur mon origine meurent
pencher sur l'histoire de mes parents je
suis plus vieux aujourd'hui que mon père
quand il nous a quittés avec ce
spectacle michel rivard replonge dans
son enfance où il jouait dans le
téléroman rues de lens et par la suite
dans l'émission rue des pignons
maintenant âgé de 67 ans il parle de la
tristesse de sa mère et de l'alcoolisme
de son père le comédien bien connu
robert rivard avec les gogos fois
pittsburgh en 2009 c'était une période
où les comédiens buvait beaucoup
ça faisait partie du rituel mon père
travaillait radio-canada d'endetter les
romains le midi vous alliez au café des
artistes qui étaient toutes là alors les
scènes tournées avant midi était bien
meilleure que celle qui tournait à trois
ans la vraie midi et je n'aimerais pas
de nom mais est en ligne
toutes nos informations biologiques sont
sur l'a6 dans cette quête de vérité
michel rivard va même jusqu'à passer un
test d'adr pour savoir une fois pour
toutes si robert rivard est son
véritable père biologique
moi j'ai eu comme cadeau ce doute locke
qui habitait la vie de mon père je vois
aller plus loin là bas on en a déjà dit
beaucoup
je voulais à tout prix et je crois que
j'ai réussi éviter le côté pipeau de la
faire moi junh et le texte et les
chansons du spectacle sont rassemblées
dans un livre disque il y as chez michel
rivard ce désir de sortir des sentiers
battus maman
ici wifi depuis mai radio-canada morère
faut pas boire et zigic est pas
[Musique]